that's Jennifer Lopez and Ben Affleck's
new 60 million dollar mega mansion
[Music]
yeah but the blocks looking a little
different these days
ET can't confirm the couple has closed
escrow on a Beverly Hills property in
the Wallingford Estates area it was
worth it so what's exactly in their
plush pad let's break it down by the
Numbers five acres 46 000 square feet 12
bedrooms and get this 24 bathrooms it's
like a whole nother level check out the
luxurious living room dining room and
staircase possibly the best part their
backyard featuring the pool of all pools
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time and for Ben who's a big Sports
guy this home is a grand slam they've
got an indoor sports complex with a
basketball court pickleball court gym
boxing ring and a lounge it's great we
imagine they'll be pretty popular
amongst the neighbors among them
yeah a source tells ET John Mayer lives
nearby oh yeah oh I did it all now ask
for what the couple paid for the
Colossal Castle well it was practically
a steal the property was originally
listed for 135 million dollars in 2018
and relisted in May for nearly 75
million but JLo and Ben scored it for
just 60. I didn't plan any of it this
way the couple who got married in a
lavish ceremony last August has been
house hunting for over two years with
several options falling through a home
is about where the people you love are
it doesn't matter what you know place
you are but those setbacks haven't
stopped benefit from enjoying newlywed
life what's the best part of this
chapter and and you know being married
to Ben there's so many things I mean I I
couldn't you don't have enough time
right now
congrats to the couple on finding their
home sweet home it's just a dream come
true
foreign